so i was not planning to stream this
morning but
uh there's been
extreme circumstances mainly hicaro
running a staffer gambit tournament
which i'm about to crash rose is a red
poem's a sappy eric streams make me
undeniably happy
oh that makes me happy and every every
game will be a stafford oh i'm white
let's play knight c3 okay
oh this is so cool i've been meaning to
like do a thematic staffer tournament
but i've just been lazy
so it's nice that hikaru is doing one
so i'm playing this line each three is
one of the
the so-called refutations black still
has play here though
also yeah welcome everyone um
i said this right when i started but i
was not planning to stream
this morning um i was i woke up i was
planning to go back to sleep
but now it's it's afro-gamba time
so we're gonna have 69 minutes of the
stafford
the goal the goal this tournament is to
play hikaru
zekaro he's not even leaning
oh maybe it just began or no
i don't know queen f3
um yeah queen f3 defending the pawn
i guess i'll be i'll be provoked to
reveal some
rep for white which i'm kind of doing
okay bishop
e3 coming yeah queen d4 is not my
move of choice it's been a while since
i've done a morning stream
69 minutes nice nice
okay so opponent is taking a lot of time
here
um suffering on christmas morning right
now
i'm so happy yeah it's like
imagine waking up and realizing
it's it's even better than christmas
it's a it's a thematic stafford
tournament play bishop e3
hitting the queen
and then d4 yeah d4 is gonna be so much
fun
black can't really can't really touch me
here
so there's no increment this is just
straight up 3-0
thank you gambi gotta be sobbing for
three months in advance
and i charon gifting five thanks so much
okay we have a very solid center
formation
um and this is probably yeah
probably what i want to do because now i
want to move over and start pushing the
the things play bishop d2 just restrict
the knight
i was threatening to win the pawn there
but yeah f f4 is coming the flag is
probably also coming
it's so nice because every game i'll be
i'll be pretty well prepared
i'm looking forward to being black
though rather than
being white um
[Music]
how to do this maybe bishop h6
is kind of interesting so bishop c2
bishop g4
there's some fun lines and some funny
lines
yeah that's gonna lose on time though
not quite mating it's close
oh my bishop black had a chance there
i did lose back the pawn but
okay that was game one we're moving on
duck or quack thank you for six months
amazing content 60 sips for six months
mr rosen
okay white moves first oh thank you
stafford hype bits stafford hype okay so
this this is a hype line yeah bishop e2
is met with queen d4 and then h5 coming
so i want to play knight g4 and and just
obliterate the king's side
go go eric yeah we're gonna have a
a fun this could be a really fun
variation
so i'm hitting f2
not easy for white to deal with also
thank you mk smoke
and rmt and jay basil and jake made cake
oh did i not sip oh i need to pour tea i
had
this one played in the first ever
recorded staffer game
wait really
i should i should know the first
recorded stafford game
uh h4 looks really nice just targeting
a lot of a lot of weak points in white's
position
i thought the first recorded stafford
game was um
it was one of these like well-known
traps i know
jonathan trance actually did a video on
it like the history of the staff right
now
um
oh my bishop's not even hanging it's
like i sack the bishop
but yeah um i just wanna keep making
progress
so probably this move threatening mate
white is surviving here
but i'll have a nice time advantage um
position is also pleasant
i guess i'm still down the pawn but i
have all the
all the active play and because white
has this structure
with the pawns on the rock squares the
light squares are a bit weak
so i was thinking bishop
is actually a funny move bishop f3
taking advantage of the pin
and my idea is to take on each two necks
it's actually a really cool line
now there are ways for white not to lose
immediately
but if white plays a slow move this
this is coming it's going to be really
nice
okay d4 good move
okay so now i'm attacking this pawn if
knight moves
to defend the pawn remember alexa's not
here right now
alexa where are you i'm so lonely
can i take this now
i think i actually i'm in trouble
my bishop's trapped let's yolo
i might lose this oh no
i'm just yellowing don't hurt me
actually it's interesting white does
have to be careful
wait this is i'm just down a rook
down the rook but i have some
still some pressure playing in the true
staffer gambit style
if i get a losing position i can still
try and win on time
hey it's irene irene's supporting
me taking on g3
um
this is the thing about stafford like
it's
i think this um is this position it's
objectively better for white but it took
so much time to get to this point yeah
i'm
down a rook but i'll win some pawns
oh no white's threatening mates
uh-oh no i can't play that
oh no i still play b5
okay it's gonna be dirty young children
close your eyes
don't take all my pawns don't do it
don't do it
hey i'm winning and i'm winning on time
okay that was dirty
i feel kind of bad there but what to do
it's all about catching up to hikaru
hey i'm black again let's go okay
a lot of okay a lot of opponents are
over 2 000
playing trickery player let's play prep
also thanks for all the hype i do
appreciate it everyone
i do have hand sanitizer last game
probably calls for
some sanitization okay
so this is my prep for carlson
which carlson did not go into but the
point is i
hit f2 trying to provoke white to castle
bishop e3 i would win this pawn hit the
rook
so white is taking their their sweet
time
thank you tangerine or tran engine
looks like tangerine and hurricane
syg
pog yeah this is such a pog turn i
should i should run these
like on my own too have a
more like thematic tournaments okay this
is now much better for black
i'm not gonna have the same sort of like
strong attack
or will i maybe i've i'll
maybe still try i could win the pawn
there's some risk involved
um and the point is after rookie one i
play bishop e6
i think everything's okay
yeah so the threat is rookie one i can't
castle
because bishop controls f8
so we'll just deal with this
oh okay i didn't see that move
um good move
brook takes okay so
i can't castle either way
i have this move i'm just controlling
the e-file
hitting the bishop
i just want the castle protect my king
thank you phil eggs and zalanoth
x two new subs
z nation welcome back
let's castle good morning eric
good morning oh yeah shout out to all
the people
in europe this is a european friendly
time
last few streams have been kind of late
evening
um let's take a pawn
backwards shish kebab
see where does the knight move
oh we have a lot of europeans it's
scotland we have oh we have asia too
shout out to europe and asia and the
rest of the continents
queen a1
okay let's play this and simplify a bit
india england yeah if you're watching on
twitch
let me know where you're from if you're
watching in the future on youtube
also let me know where you're from
i need to start asking the future
youtube people more
more questions get them engaged in the
comments
man chad is going so fast look at this
chad is going really fast okay um
let's try and win quickly
going for the quick meets
not quite quick meeting though
i think it's it's more likely i'll win
on time again
i'm winning a lot of games on time
whoa psychedelic gazelle gifting 65 subs
thanks so much that's huge
it's one way to wake up in the morning
really appreciate that
welcome back
if you're gifted a sub you have the the
thank you emote
say thank you to psychedelic gazelle
oh that was that wasn't close to
stalemate even
okay okay good try
um hey i'm black again oh i'm playing a
strong player though
uh okay let's unleash some prep
so i'm i'm playing this line again we
had this line
very recently um and then h5
so the whole idea i want to play knight
g4
target f2
um yeah i know white subject will be
better here
if white plays correctly which is not
always a guarantee
ooh that's a move
let's retreat
and then the plan is to
start attacking somehow
because i have to move back
the the issue in some of these lines is
this move bishop f4
which uh just have to deal with
and we'll castle and start targeting the
center
it is hard to actually attack on the
king side
but i might try and do so anyway like
maybe start with rook h5
but then knight f4 so let's start with
queen h6
some idea f5 poke at the center
okay we'll put the bishop here
oh and thinks yeah it might take a while
for the the sub alerts to be right off
i just blunder upon i kind of just
blundered upon
oh no my position i know i'm down two
pawns
um there's this move
chasing my way and then bishop e6
probably
so i want to play f5
and time is good
getting better too if i was not easy to
stop
the thing is the more pawns i lose the
more open files i gain
uh okay white wants to trap my bishop
probably have to make some
some bubble
i also have g4 to consider but g4 it
gives away too many squares
okay so now i'm trying to trough the
bishop i can take with rook bishop
i have bishop d5 as well
[Music]
stick with bishop actually stick with
rook
staying flexible because i might end up
playing this
if queen here there's funny move rookie
five
so now c7 is a bit tender
i think it's okay oh there's some weird
meeting idea though
like here here here there's a puzzle
rush weird weirdness
um i have to be really careful here
bishop d7 maybe rook
or cure it's not the most aesthetic
the idea of this and this
at some point i might play king here
just give my bishop a square
i'm just trying to hold on get ready for
the the time scramble
hit the knight defend the pawn
knight c5 i think i just take it
[Music]
now we have obstacle bishops
um i gotta move quicker
for the rook trade
if we do trade rooks and i'll be
threatening queen e4
it's probably a good move
i just want to target g2 somehow it's
not easy though
i might win on time again have the time
advantage
uh play this move
oh tricky play this move
so cunning off the pin
and then this move i don't mind the
trade
or the sacrifice
time scramble time
bishop f7 was kind of dirty
wow wow
i took all of white's things let's go
okay
i was really dirty
like wiped me the wrong pre-moves i made
the right pre-moves
what was that that's so funny
oh i feel so accomplished but also so
dirty
okay have to kill 99
of the germs hey i'm light okay let's
play
the slime again yeah i think i'll stick
with the
the basic um oh bishop b4
novelty i've never seen this before
let's play e e5 and try and punish this
and then d4
yeah the main move after knight c3 is
bishop's e5 it's like
the move you almost always play in the
stafford
okay um let's
let's think about trading but i think
it's nice leaving the tension
uh castle
i feel like have i won all my games on
time so far i think i have
let's try and win a game by mating
um this pawn's attacked
so i can defend
some idea f4 f5 or just lunge the a pawn
okay we can trade
what country is this very colorful
country
need to learn my flags mauritius
i think i have like a a viewer from
mauritius or maybe a few viewers
have to check my analytics
um okay we're gonna simplify a little
bit
if black wants
or not okay let's keep pushing
oh maybe i could give black a pawn cube
oh this pawn's attack though g3
wait mess this up
i may have messed up a little bit
how do i do this in queen 92
just want to play c3
happy two months oh these were from much
earlier
ah my pawn
black's playing this well the power of
the stafford
okay let's play also my time
i'll play knight g3 so i lost back upon
um
yeah it's it's kind of balanced here but
also imbalanced
we both still want to attack knight here
controls h5
so it's hard for the rook to swing over
gutten morgan eric
oh guten morgen or gutten morgan
okay let's start pushing hey thank you
primo nap
hello thanks for the three dollars
files are ready to open on the queen
side
so it takes all take with uh the thing
this case all yeah go for queen f3.5
why did i not take the rook on e5 um
there's oh yeah i could have actually
maybe i should probably should have
get two rooks for it there's some issue
with bishop e3
let's go rosen i probably should have
though
okay let's move quicker
yeah i think it's all for thanks for all
the bits and support i do appreciate it
ooh black avoiding the queen train
bishop d5 coming
okay let's take here
i do want to try and make things sharp
like c4 perhaps wow what is this move
let's take that bishop d5 might be
coming but then queen f5
also the bishop's still hanging
okay life is good
threatening to take and then infiltrate
um any quick mates
maybe this first
i'm gonna win another game on time
uh actually maybe i'll mate
it's close let's go it's mate
okay gotta check maiden
so what place am i in thank you eric
undefeated so far
oh thank you
i did late join so there's okay just
under 42 minutes left
hikaru is playing the goal is either to
play hikaru or pass akaru
hikaru is also streaming shout out to
hikaru
yeah so when i play h3 i don't have to
worry about uh like bishop g4
or knight g4
i'll employ some more solid setup
oh thank you psychedelic gazelle yeah
let's go
and try and keep the pace keep the tempo
momentum
i'm getting a lot of the same positions
but it can never really have too much
staffer gambit
so much fun
okay we might see a pawn cube very soon
it's going very well thanks for asking
and thanks for subbing
75 oh i could take it right away
i can yeah i think it's maybe better to
leave the tension
normally it's good if black takes
okay let's give black upon cube
the first pawn cube sighting of the
stream
it's so cubular
okay normally pong queues are
indestructible
but i'm gonna try and destroy it
and we're gonna start by getting the
rooks in prime position
and then winning connect four almost
trapping the bishop
bishop has to move back or
that and it's a fork pin
okay that was nice hey the pawn cube
survived it was indestructible
for those saying it's a square um
it's three dimensional because it
survived through time
but i kind of understand why it's maybe
some people think it's a square
oh bishop d3 uh
is kind of a funny move let's play
let's just do the usual i guess i could
have started with
knight g4 but the usual
is the
the hyper aggressive attack on the king
side
the problem with bishop d3 even though
it does defend the pawn it blocks this
pawn
which blocks a bishop and just slows
down the queen side development
and this bishop like usually the bishop
wants to be here or here
because on d3 it's blocked by its own
pawns
so i like to call this a pointless
bishop it doesn't really have a point
um so i have this move
and then there's actually a funny line
if c3
saving the rook hitting my bishop i play
this move with a double threat of taking
on d3 but also threatening a greek gift
i'm set up for the greek gift because i
played h5
the greek gift is just the sequence
takes here and then here
and bishop e2 looks like the natural way
to stop
it but it still walks into
a lot of trouble i didn't take on b4
even though it was a seemingly free pawn
it's more fun to
um to checkmate
to attack on the king's side this should
lead to mate
three months three years three decades
three centuries three lifetimes and many
more
oh and three months love you and thank
you oh you said three months
thank you aki and thanks to my opponent
for
being generous sir okay
that was nice game um okay
we're going into this again playing a
decently high rated player
so these games aren't rated i just
realized my rating is
it's a kind of lucky number
so i'm in oh i'm in 12th place
now 13th slowly but surely i have 25
tournament points
opponent perplexed
i'm drinking uh toasted coconut black
tea today
from from a scrabble mug shout out to
josh who sent me this
from montreal okay opponent um
might end up flagging because position
is so complicated
uh castling at castling is respectable
i think now all i'll just play solidly
have you ever played squash i've eaten
squash
squash is like um it's a pumpkin like
vegetable
related to maybe a sweet potato too
but i don't recall like playing the
sports
a sport is far different from the food
f5 may be coming tempted to play
g4 also tempted just to
trade things
play this move first
okay keeping some time advantage i have
not played recaro yet
not sure if the timing will work out but
um could be fun to play
play hikaru in the stafford
uh yeah f5 was expected and now the
question is what to do with my queen
here's a funny line just bishop e2
allowing takes takes bishop d5 and then
queen d4 bishop g2 rook g1
hitting g7
also enjoying the the time advantage
here
yeah it looks a little bit shaky
because let's say
let's play queen g3 black does have some
pressure i just have to
not get forked you could probably now
take
still up upon solid position
not getting mated bishop pair
life is good okay bishop f3
bishop g5 coming
this pawn is a bit tender and pinned
so now the knight is pinned to g7
oh this is also a free pawn hitting this
pawn and this pawn
took a moment to spot
so i was thinking about rookie one but
yeah queen c7 is much simpler
97 would defend but then would allow for
rookie one from scotland
oh hi to scotland thank you alabama
solving for four months
okay time is good um
man so many fun looking moves here
let's play rook rookie five looks fun
just want to double up
okay here i can take
and keep applying the pressure
okay that was nice
i mean it is nice having like devoted a
serious
portion of my life to studying this
opening so
um nice to be prepared in a lot of the
games
oh did this guy beat hikaru oh maybe he
beat hikaru from the the white side
oh this is rated too oh i didn't realize
this was rated
oh my rating went up nice
i didn't think thematic games were rated
but um
oh let's uh yeah let's farm some people
playing what looks to be geary okay
let's play
h5 h5 is one of the
the moves i i like to play against h3
um again with bishop d3
oh happy three months marco polo
so bishop d3 it's um yeah it just slows
down development
it's probably still okay or
actually this is going to be really fun
there's a line where the bishop's on e2
knight e2 oh wow
so i could take on f2 here
there's line takes takes takes in c3
so maybe i'll play this move i'm just
threatening meat
so i'm still in 13th place
leader has 42 points
yeah i don't think this is actually giri
yeah normally i'd like to take care of
the knight defense unfortunately
so what to do i could play h4
h4 looks so reckless but also so fun
i'm just letting the night perish
and the night is very perishable the
point is to
start opening files mainly the h file
also target g3 and take advantage of the
fact white is a bit slow with
the queen side development
yeah i think the way the pairings work
is you don't play
people close to your standing you play
people close to your rating
so it kind of levels out the competition
uh let's take this way hello eric
hello okay on poisson's not legal here
but this is legal oh this is so much fun
threatening a few different mates in one
if rook here i have bishop f3
should just be force mate i think it's
already force made from this position
because this is one of the only moves to
not get mated and then
yada yada oh that's made already okay
uh that was nice yeah this is why like
usually you should not put the bishop
on d3 blocking your d-pawn
did i miss made in one i found
i found the ventral mate okay so i'm
black again
yeah on poisson's not legal when the
pawn comes
like when you have a pawn on the third
rank you can only do on poisson when the
pawns on the fourth rank
okay let's um let's focus
for those confused you can google on
poisson
oh this is the first time we're getting
like the the magical line
the jonathan tron's magical line of
greatness
um opponent doesn't seem so well
prepared also seems maybe to be
struggling
with some lag zimbabwe wow
never been to zimbabwe
yeah so i'm threatening f2 g3 i move
back
oh hicaro keeps moving up
oh we're close and standing though
kind of
okay so best to take with bishop hit the
queen
one of the benefits of the queen here it
defends upon on f2
castle here
oh no my bishop da
white's not taking it okay let's move
back
that pawn takes rook d1 which could have
been interesting
um white still can't castle
so maybe i'll keep
just keep applying pressure
one of the nice things when you play
staffer like you have you don't have any
center pawns
so the two center files are open for the
rooks
so these pawns even though they're they
could be considered strong they're also
potential targets
have ideas of eventually this or this
yeah so this pawns pin this pawns pins
well it's probably threatening g3
so i should probably take some action
there's this funny move
it's actually kind of a funny move oh no
my bishop
my calculation is if g3 i take on e4
counter attacking and of course if takes
here
this pawn's pinned i can take on e3
so a lot of pins in the in the position
also the pawns attack three times
i don't think it can be defended another
time
yes i'll win the pawn
i guess we're just trading into a
pleasant end game
yeah sometimes this will happen where
you don't quite get your
your strong attack but you you win back
material and
life goes on oh it's under a lot of
pressure here so now the
this pawn's pinned um
reinforcer rook yeah four attackers
against d4
oh it's so tempting to take
also tempting to play this move i think
it's best just to leave all the tension
i didn't see anything immediate there
yeah we'll shift over so now white can't
play rookie one i'm ready to play rookie
two
c4
c4 might not do so much but i'll play it
anyway
white has a choice now
yeah so here i can take and move in
win back upon
maybe go after this guy
why wants to trap my bishop
oh i shared um i did share
i could share it after this uh this
tournament too
there is a website in progress
bishop's not getting trapped on d4
um let's attack the thing
oh no my bishop
so if takes i i skewer
also i think i'm winning material now
because
oh there's that move now i can take
yeah this is just really pleasant
okay that was nice we move on
picarwyn third place man oh i'm playing
a strong player
bear glove at least i'm white
okay castling so we'll play this
and play in a similar style as
previously
b5 b5
b5 is playable bishop g5 maybe just a3
actually
this move
yeah i remember actually studying like
some of these lines as black
like this is um i remember this is one
of the engine ideas
uh can i just take oh i can't take on c7
uh let's just castle probably
okay now we're both playing very solidly
i want to play probably f4 eventually
knight c5 interesting
let's expand
maybe expand further black wants to play
knight d4
oh let's expand further should put the
king on each one
yeah good move maybe rook c1
hey minku with a thousand bits thanks so
much
black is playing this well and getting
kind of the
positional compensation um let's move
back maybe go for c3
oh i blundered kind of or did i
this might still be okay hit the hit the
uh that file
i forgot i was pinned wow queen d6
crazy move that defends everything
actually
man okay i just lost my whole advantage
i was expecting knight takes i guess
black was still using the pin there
a strong player probably go for king h2
eventually
those might come down to time
i'm just trying to play quickly
so i lost back the pawn i mean we have a
queenless middle game
type thing
oh no
okay i just got forked
i could resign i'm gonna fight on though
this is bishop e8
the king on e2
i do have time black's moving a little
bit slowly
okay that gave me some nice opportunity
and it's not gonna be easy to survive
here though
let's move
i'm down with full rook
box moving really slowly though
very strange play
what is your connection to indonesia i
ready speak bahasa
oh really that's cool
how's this player 2600
it's actually really confusing and
offering a draw
uh no draw
before oh man i might still lose though
it's
it's gonna be close
no i got mated
oh
what to do ah
that was a really really strange game oh
no my king
oh thanks for the raid henrik b if
you're just joining i just lost my first
game of the stream
um that was a strange game
because the opening though like first
stage of the game was really strong from
the opponent
and then um the time the time scramble
was
uh was very strange
i missed yeah i missed the fork knight
f1
okay so h5 i'll play d3
yeah shout out to henrik henrik b
do you appreciate the rain release just
joining
i'm playing caro's stafford gambit
tournament
um there's 16 minutes left
so we'll try and finish strong
i'm trying to catch up to hikaru who's
in third place
but yeah unfortunately after that loss i
lose my my whole streak
and some of my hope
i played the karo the only time i've
played stafford
against takaru was a few years ago
i was trying to find the vod but um
i think it got deleted and i didn't save
it
thank you deadly dust 96.
okay hitting the queen
um
i'm gonna try and play quickly i wanna
have time for a few more games
have i ever been into tetris have you
ever been into tetris
i went through a phase when i was much
younger you used to be able to play on
facebook
but i haven't played in a long time
that's one of those like childhood
nostalgia games
i know there's a competitive tetris
scene though
also if a6 i play a5
so black plays 85 let's play c3 trying
to chip away at the
structure so now black either takes this
way
i have a five ideas or takes this way
and ricci want ideas
oh no my knight
but we're basically just trading
at some point i might end up taking on
g7
or any mating ideas
it feels close
um
so close yet so far
maybe this move so i'm preparing like
rook a
e5 etc
and now i'll take i want to remove the
knight so like knight h5 then there's no
more
eventual knight d5 okay let's play this
move threatening
some kind of windmill
okay it's windmill time
good to see you streaming hopefully the
chucks keep coming crush me with the
stafford
oh someday
uh let's check and then take this way
and then push hitting this yeah
tough finish for black after king never
mind let's um
let's not even take the queen let's just
finish the game in style
that was nice okay
feel good game after that that previous
one
okay playing another person
no
that was reflexive i just i fell into
the most common
staffer trap will my opponent know what
to do
they do oh no
okay i mean it's not so bad it's just
how do i do that
i played d3 i was supposed to play h3
that's the thing like you can't get
complacent as white when you play
against a staffer
i know that karu fell into this once too
yeah bishop d4 best move
um let's just pretend
everything's okay
so i want to play c3 redevelop and
try not to embarrass myself further
oh no don't hurt me
okay lock's not hurting me
black did win back the pawn so now it's
equal material
um and we have a game
i wouldn't mind just simplifying a
little bit even stafford man himself
falls into its traps
yeah i'm gonna try not to lose though
i guess the one game i lost the stream i
was i was white
playing against the stafford
it's kind of the extra pressure here
okay so here oh let's not hang upon
let's um
let's try and win a pawn
oh taking
taking probably doesn't work let's play
play this move making things spicy
so there's a line takes
takes and then
black can't easily win the pawn because
there's back rank issues
i think oops let's um
yeah like takes takes etc and then mate
now black's threatening to win the pawn
so let's defend
and this is just kind of a equal-ish
position black's probably slightly
better
my pawns are a bit weak
of course i'm playing to win maybe going
for the the dirty flag
by a4 here if rook comes in then i can
come in
yeah this is actually getting really
interesting i'm threatening maiden one
bishop moves i have a5
oh no bishop c5 would hit my queen
wow so let's start with the check
i'm thinking queen f1
there's also there is b4 here b4 queen
c3
i don't know what's going on there let's
play queen b1
threatening the the sly
double attack b4 is still on the radar
just to trap the bishop
that's probably a practical decision
this should be better now for for white
still threatening to trap the bishop
yeah these these pieces are oh i forgot
about that
i was just ready to insult black's
pieces
i'm still threading this yeah the pieces
are clunky
but i don't have any more pawns
where'd my ponds go also
do you want to trade queens let's trade
queens play maybe
we'll okay black's not getting a pawn
cube
this should be winning for white the
problem for black there's going to be
some eventual zugswong
let's attack the pawn first
oh how do i do this
okay trying to come in from behind
play a waiting move
there we go oh i can't take the pawn
because i get forked and then i lose
uh let's move this way
and then this way okay now i cut the
king off so this is a zouzong
and then i can win the pawn like so
like wesley so or like this
okay rook d2 was almost played there
okay now we'll have a instruction on how
to meet
okay took some time one more game
i'm playing the same players before
okay they they rolled over me before
bishop e2
play queen d4 again
wait queenie one don't think this is a
good line
maybe it's still playable for white
though
thanks for the bits thousand bits
[Music]
from oh from real
silky turd there's no tts because
um i'll read your message in a moment
but let's try and survive this first
let's take actually probably have to
to save the bishop
actually no i can take first because i
hit this bishop
and now i can take here
i'm not calculating everything but i'm
calculating some things
this might end up in like a really quick
win actually
so if knight takes bishop i play this
takes and then i'm
mating if takes this way i have this and
i think i'm mating
so i'm not sure what white does here
oh real silky turd says been watching
for a while on youtube you're awesome
man
you helped me kill a lot of time while
flying nice
your voice is godlike i can't wait to
play you one day
thanks for being a dope personality i
really appreciate that
some kind words there yeah i'm pretty
sure this is force mate
or um i don't know if it's force mate
but uh
that's maybe an extreme saying but if if
takes
and if takes and it should be force mate
if here then it's also force mate
oh queen d1
not getting mated but here i take the
rook
hey eric thanks for making chess fun for
me
oh thank you for being fun rossa boss
okay let's focus here i guess white's
[Music]
surviving
go for some trade i mean i'm up to
exchange
pawns are equal this could be the last
game of the tournament actually
because i have queen h6 which i probably
need to play if i take there is queen e2
uh i don't mind trading
can't believe it's been nine months of
oh no stars and staffords
thanks for helping me with my chess
oh thank you you're zero oh oh oh no's
daws and staffords
yeah my favorite things in life
okay this will take a little bit of
patience here
i want to put the rook on the d file
okay opponent resigns let's go one maybe
time for one more but probably not
oh karo is in first
i'm in sad ninth
yeah i think what happens usually like
at the end of an arena tournament
if the tournament timer goes out or goes
to zero the game just gets aborted
so not playing acaro this tournament
try and finish aggressively though
b3
yeah this is already really fun
oh am i not meeting
the the tournament time is going to run
out unfortunately
it's completely winning though
okay that was fun gotta put that on
youtube
a stafford gambit i crashed karu's
staffer gabba tournament
didn't play hikaru but good job to
hikaru